you may have noticed that prices are
going up on just about everything and if
you've been listening to companies talk
about these price increases you've
probably heard a lot of crying
woes me we have no choice but to raise
our prices our labor costs are going up
our inputs our inputs
but that's a lie
here's the truth about inflation
companies love it
i'm going to tell you why
show you how they benefit and explain
why it is that we're seeing such wide
ranging price increases right now
inflation isn't something that just
happens people make it happen
when companies make statements about
their new higher prices to the public
they frame it as something they have to
do
like here when pepsico cfo hugh johnston
told bloomberg the company was raising
prices to
deal with inflation
but in reality companies aren't being
forced to raise prices because of
inflation they're raising prices because
they can i know this because i've
listened to company earnings calls like
this one
building on the strength of our brands
we are thoughtfully executing tailored
price increases
and this one too we expect to continue
delivering positive pricing
even though we are lapping strong mid
single digit price increases in the
second half of 2020.
you see when companies talk to investors
about prices rising they make it clear
that this helps rather than hurts the
business
so we we view a little bit of inflation
is always good in our business to be
sure firms around the world are
absolutely facing rising costs for
materials labor and more but they're
raising prices by significantly more
than that
we know this because of net margins in
layman's terms net margin is the
percentage of profit that a company
earns from every dollar of sales over
the past year companies net margins have
risen to record highs and net margins
are expected to rise again over the next
year in fact
analysts are expecting companies to
deliver record margins this year as in
the largest gap between companies costs
and their profits in history and at the
same time economists and stock analysts
are also expecting inflation to steadily
decline so firms are expecting to keep
raising prices even though the price
increases they say are forcing their
hand are slowing down
naturally corporations love this because
it fattens the bottom line and data show
how they're using these record profits
they're buying back stock to push their
share prices higher and they're giving
raises and bonuses to top executives
but why is it that companies can do this
doesn't our economics 101 textbook tell
us that when companies raise prices
smaller more efficient firms step in
disrupt their business and steal their
customers
well yes but while congress has done a
lot of talking about updating u.s
antitrust laws the past 30 years has
seen weak policy from the government and
a massive concentration of companies
75 percent of all american industries
have become more concentrated in the
last two decades that means there's just
less competition out there and big
companies have more influence and thanks
to the coronavirus pandemic and the
federal reserve large corporations have
another leg up in march 2020 the fed
announced it would buy unlimited u.s
treasury bonds as well as debt from
american companies including those with
junk credit ratings that allowed big
businesses to borrow money for
incredibly low costs the lowest in
history for many because investors knew
the fed was purchasing corporate bonds
to steady the market they were willing
to buy just about anything that led to
companies issuing a record amount of
debt and using the money to shield
themselves from competition
small businesses on the other hand who
aren't large enough to issue debt on
public markets found it exceptionally
difficult to borrow money banks
tightened up their credit standards and
commercial and industrial lending
plummeted so big corporations loaded
themselves up with cash that they could
use to push smaller competitors out of
the market or buy them and just like
that there's a lot less competition to
worry about now conglomerates like
kimberly clark procter gamble and
unilever can raise prices and feel
confident that customers will keep
paying nearly 100 of the biggest u.s
publicly traded companies booked 2021
profit margins that were at least 50
percent higher than their 2019 levels
that was a big part of the record retail
sales numbers we saw last year
that and customers panicked buying
because they were expecting prices to
keep going up so the next time you hear
about a company raising prices because
of inflation know that it's actually the
other way around companies are raising
their prices and as a result inflation's
probably going to keep rising if you
enjoyed this video hit the like button
and if you're interested in markets and
want to watch and learn more subscribe
to this channel to keep up with my
latest
in the words the mighty most deaf time
is money and money is time and a dang
thing free so i gotta get mine that's it
for now i'll see you next time